Hi there, me again.
Now as the very famous expert on language acquisition has said, Stephen Krashen, you need input.
You need a lot of the language.
You don't have the language in you, you have to get it in. You you get it in you through a lot of listening and
reading, but you have to take charge.
Take the time to understand how our system works, even if at first there seems to be a lot of different functions,
take the time. It's worth it. And then take the ti me to find
content, lessons that you find meaningful, that you find enjoyable. If you choose something in the library
you don't like, or something, a
lesson is recommended to you that you don't like, do something else. Take the initiative.
Develop that... that tendency to take the initiative. It's going to be the secret to your success.
Find content that you like, and listen and read and listen and read and you'll be surprised
how your brain will get used to the language.